what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar and today just as we examine the
yonko supernova warlords and so on in
past videos
today we are looking at the
revolutionaries and what we know about
their unique powers
specifically in this one we'll be
looking at dragon as commanders
and everything we know about their own
personal unique abilities the
revolutionary army is one of the most
interesting forces in one piece as they
seek to change the world by dismantling
the world government
they want a freer better world where the
world nobles cannot oppress the rest of
the world's peoples
how can i not be excited to talk about
an organization with such ambitious and
awesome goals
especially when it's headed by the
monkey d dragon
the world's worst criminal but first if
you do enjoy these one piece videos they
want to keep them coming the best
you could do is channel the piraking
within and smash that like button with
no mercy until it's blue
if you do want to see these kinds of
videos for shanks's crew blackbeard's
crew whitebeard's crew and so on
then make sure to smash that like button
and leave a comment for
which specific topic you'd like me to
cover next if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos
as you wait for the next video to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist
that includes videos on all the yonko
admirals fruits
and much more like that is in
description and you can also leave
topics you are burning up to see
in the comments and now without further
ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all let's start with the chief of
staff sabo
aka luffy's other big bro who inherited
ace's devil fruit the man or men don't
know me
or the flame flame fruit sabo's bounty
is 602 million berries which is honestly
surprising since he is the number two of
the revolutionary army only second to
monkey the dragon himself who is
commonly known as the world's
worst criminal as a result i would have
liked to see his bounty at at least one
billion
but that's a conversation for another
day notably he's a master of ryu sulkin
aka
the dragon claw fists fighting style
this style is hand based and allows him
to use his grip to accomplish
truly insane feats sabo compares his
fingers to the claws of a dragon
and they let him stop and then destroy
vice admiral bastille's
giant shark cleaver he was able to crush
the vice admiral's metal mask with one
hand
as he tells us that he can crush the
human skull as easily as an egg
you definitely don't want to mess with
this guy without even trying he flexes
on this vice admiral and leaves him out
of commission then as mentioned he now
has the mera mera no me
a logi of fruit that lets him use the
properties of fire to his advantage he
can create it manipulate it and turn
into it
leaving him immune to normal physical
attacks he has also inherited
aces famous fire fist move an attack
that creates a concentrated stream of
fire that can take out multiple ships in
one
shot i really like the fact that sabo
inherited this fruit because it's a way
of keeping ace and his memories
alive and you can bet that the more sabo
masters his fruit the more
op it's gonna be especially when he used
it in conjunction with his amazing
dragon claw fist fighting style
additionally sabo uses a long pipe to
fight with
and can infuse it with haki or set it
ablaze with his logia powers
in addition to being able to use
armament haki he can use observation
haki as well we got a taste of what sabo
is capable of when he fought
burgess one of blackbeard's 10 titanic
captains and more specifically the
captain of the first
ship sabo completely overpowered one of
blackbeard's strongest men
and finished it all off fittingly with a
fire fist after the titanic captain
tried to disrespect ace's memory
sabo was never in trouble here it was
less one-sided when he exchanged blows
with an admiral specifically with the
meteor dropping admiral fujitora this
admiral can manipulate gravity and make
it feel like you're using bulma's
gravity machine
on steroids during this fight sabo held
his own
until the two realized they had no real
reason to fight in this instance and
parted ways without a clear winner then
we were also told that the captains of
the revolutionary army bust into sacred
marijua
to rescue kuma and clash with navy
admirals ryokugyu
and fujitora in the process
unfortunately we didn't see this fight
in right now we don't know exactly how
it concluded but it doesn't look good
for sabo since in chapter 956
there was some news about sabo that
seriously distressed his comrades and
friends who read it
even dragon was sweating but he decided
that their first focus must be to
ascertain the truth of the matter so
yeah here's hoping that we will get to
see
sabo again because it would seriously
not be cool
to lose him after we lost ace next we
have karasu
the 47 year old commander of the north
army with a bounty of 400 million karasu
can use armament and observation
haki but the really unique thing about
him is his unnamed devil fruit which
allows him to turn himself into a bunch
of crows
very reminiscent of hitachi from naruto
he can manipulate the countless crows
and even use them to grab the weapons of
his enemies or to carry his friends
he can turn into crows in order to fly
and transport himself but also the crows
can serve as a line of communication
between members of the revolutionary
army that's pretty much what we know for
now
we haven't seen him go all out in a
fight but the dude
at least visually definitely doesn't
look like someone you want to mess with
i look forward to seeing how his powers
will be used against a powerful
one-on-one opponent
but for now let's move on to bella betty
the commander of the east army
who will most definitely get you pumped
up this attracted 34 year old has a
bounty of 457 million berries even
higher than that of karasu betty is
considered to be the flag bearer of
freedom because with
a single wave of her banner she can call
forth the strength of people
specifically of oppressed people by
speaking to them and encouraging them
she raises their resolve and physical
strength the power helped ordinary
citizens overcome the peach beard
pirates with sticks
no small feat it is a very unique power
and a perfect one for a revolutionary
currently in the wano arc the go
metaphor has emphasized the importance
of numbers
not just strong individuals in conflicts
and if betty could get countless people
to rise up that could be a nightmare for
the celestial dragons and the marines so
i totally understand why her bounty
would be even higher than karasu's
she can also use armament and
observation hockey next up we have the
mini skirt wearing giant morley
the commander of the west army the 160
year old's bounty is
293 million berries just being a giant
comes with certain advantages like
increased strength and a longer lifespan
like ariel's dad morally wields a
trident
except instead of moving around in the
sea he moves around in the ground
he ate the oshioshi no me a paramecia
fruit which lets him manipulate the
ground as if it were clay he can push
and mold it to his will
whether he's sending a wave of it at his
enemies or just
traveling through it effortlessly from a
revolutionary perspective it's probably
very useful for getting into hard to
reach locations
like the others he can use armament and
observation hockey
again we've seen these guys easily
overcome the peachbeard pirates but i
hope we get a chance to see them all
being pushed closer to their limits in a
prolonged fight so we can get a better
sense of what they're truly capable of
next up we have lindbergh the cat mink
commander of the south army what's not
to love about this 37 year old steampunk
cat his bounty is a solid 316 million
berries
as a mink lint is a natural born fighter
and is capable of channeling electricity
via electro into his attacks and or
weapons
not only are the attacks strengthened
they can lead to burns or even paralysis
add in a full moon and we may get to see
lind
undergo a soolong transformation which
would be very hype
once transformed all existing skills
will be amplified and the mink's body
will be surrounded by electro sparks
like they just went
super saiyan 2. aside from this lind is
an inventor
and uses his gadgets in battle he flies
around with a jet pack which is very
cool
almost as cool as this cool shooter that
has the power to freeze weapons or
people like mr freeze himself
as usual this commander can use armament
and observation hockey
overall this cat dude is one of my
favorite commanders since i think his
design is amazing
can't wait to see his soolong form can't
wait to see his other inventions and as
usual
can't wait to see what it looks like
when he's pushed to his limits in battle
fun fact there are theories based on
lindbergh's name that he could be a
traitor and that the revolutionary plan
at the reverie went sour because he
betrayed his comrades but that's just
the theory at this point and i'm really
hoping that this steampunk cat lives up
to my high expectations of him
next up we have emporio ivankov
aka eva the commander of the g army aka
the grand line army of the
revolutionaries
ivankov is 43 years old after the
timeskip and is also known as the queen
of the kamabaka kingdom the okama king
and a miracle person clearly eva does
not conform to any one label
we don't know his exact bounty currently
but we do know he was kept in level 5 of
impel
down a place where criminals with
bounties of 100 million and over are
kept eva has plenty of techniques up his
sleeves one of which includes the death
wink
from a wink he can create shock waves
strong enough to send back projectiles
or to just do massive damage
if being able to accomplish so much with
just a wink isn't a giant flex
i don't know what is yvonne cove
possesses the hormhorn fruit a paramecia
fruit which turns one into a
hormone-controlling human
as eva explains it he can freely
manipulate hormones at will
gender body temperature pigmentation
growth excitement he is an
engineer of the human body who can alter
people from the inside
eva can turn men to woman or woman to
men by injecting the right
hormones through his fingertips he can
use this ability on himself
too eva even saved luffy from poisoning
by stimulating his natural immunity
factors to abnormal levels
and altering his body to enable him to
fight off the poisons inside him
according to eva he just changed luffy's
survival rate from zero to two or three
percent
luffy survived the insanely painful
process thanks to his own willpower but
the fact remains in the end that eva's
abilities were powerful enough to help
save our protagonist
eva is also a master of new kama kempo
aka new kama karate
the ultimate form of fighting from the
kama bakka kingdom one of eva's notable
fights was against magellan
the vice warden of impel down and the
possessor of the venom venom fruit
hilariously enough a thick layer of
makeup served to protect eva's face
against magellan's poison in one
instance ultimately
magellan did overpower eva but eva did
buy some time and did survive to boot
with a little help from healing hormones
and then went on to help luffy even more
during the paramount war
eva survived attacks by magma admiral
akainu
again thanks in part to the thick layer
of makeup and eva was even strong enough
to send the powerful kuma flying back
with winks and a kick like a true
revolutionary ivankov doesn't take
credit for miracles but says others make
miracles possible
when they never give up but despite his
humbleness i think we can all agree that
he's earned the title of a miracle
person
now let's turn to the supreme commander
of the revolutionary army himself
monkey the dragon the father of our main
protagonist
and the man known as the world's worst
criminal probably the coolest title in
the entire series he is
55 years old after the time skip and his
bounty has yet to be revealed
it should be at the very least over a
billion berries but my hope is that
since he is considered the world's worst
criminal he will have the highest bounty
of
any living character that being said
since sabo's is so low compared to some
yonko commanders it's totally possible
and maybe even likely that dragon's
bounty won't be as high as i wish it to
be
we know dragon's gotta be strong when we
look at his position
and who his father and son are but the
other big reason his bounty should be
high is because as robin pointed out
while pirates usually don't attack the
government or navy on their own
dragon and the revolutionaries directly
challenge them we're told the government
is angry and continuously searching for
dragon but to no avail
the fact that dragon has been able to
avoid capture
and even continue to act for so long
shows how much of a threat he truly
is we're further told that he is a man
of mystery and that no one knows
anything about him but here we will look
at what else we do know
we do know that he appeared when it
looked like smoker had captured luffy
during chapter 100
and by doing so he helps luffy escape
when asked why he helped luffy he simply
said and i quote what reason would i
have to get in the way of another man's
voyage
end quote smoker 100 knew the government
was after dragon's head
and yet we didn't even see him trying to
capture dragon smoker probably knew that
he was
way out matched to even try furthermore
after ivankov saved luffy and found
out that he was dragon's son he thought
that that would explain luffy's
almost superhuman vitality another
subtle nod to dragon's own strength
we could also speculate about monkey d
dragon's possible devil fruit as well
there's reason to believe that he has a
wind-based logia fruit or a more
generally weather based power
the wind examples are most obvious when
he steps in to save luffy from smoker
there are suddenly huge gusts of wind
that spread throughout the town and even
shatter rock
these gusts of wind help luffy escape
then during chapter 587
in a flashback when luffy and ace are
surrounded by flames
suddenly a path is opened up leading to
the revolutionary ship
the too good to be true path could have
been easily created with the help of
dragon's powerful gusts of wind
then during chapter 794 we see dragon
grab sabo's hand
after the ladders shipwreck and then he
later appears on his own revolutionary
ship
being told he's late and we can see what
looks like wind coming off of him
the ability to turn into wind and
transport using wind explains how he
could suddenly swoop in to save sabo so
quickly
and it would explain why trying to
capture him is so difficult if not
pointless because he could use his
powers to escape from practically every
situation however we've also seen
rain accompany dragon and specifically
it's hard to believe that the lightning
that saved luffy from his execution was
a coincidence
especially since dragon was present so
rather than just a straightforward wind
logia fruit as i mentioned there are
theories they could have a more general
weather weather fruit and there are also
theories that he could have a well
dragon fruit to match his name
specifically it could be a mythical zone
of a type of eastern
air dragon called a weatherlord
weatherlords are said to control the
weather
clouds and winds and bring life-giving
rain to the land
that last part sounds especially fitting
for a revolutionary they can also summon
a storm
when angered and keep in mind it
suddenly started raining when goldie
roger a dude who loved freedom was
executed and dragon was present there
too
so although it's all a theory this
latter theory could fit more of the
strange occurrences we've seen than just
a straightforward wind logia fruit let
me know what you think about the nature
of dragon's devil fruit but whatever
ends up being the case i'm sure oda
won't disappoint especially
after keeping dragon shrouded in mystery
and hype
for so long but i think that's enough
for dragon for the purposes of this
video i hope you enjoyed this one and if
you did you know what to do channel the
revolutionary within and smash that like
button until it's blue like you are
smashing the foundations of the world
government itself i'm thinking of doing
these kinds of videos for other
organizations like blackbeard and his 10
titanic captains explained so if that's
something you want to see definitely
make sure that like button is pressed
and let me know in the comments if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko
admirals fruits and much more link to
that is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans in grota but they have the
al-jatal hinokami and water
the toasted she the spike eight two two
seven emperor otaku spidey life tanel
tungsten tarques big buddhist
cody hebert and monkey d quilly and our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
gilgamesh
the red haired raven angel cruz rethu
and deiora very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks joanne garcia ted no ted
fatboy games cory mcgohan and soul rise
slice and dice thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar or you can
become a channel member here on youtube
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested and as i mentioned you
can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way
if you prefer whichever way to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you